- Hi everybody, I'm Maurice Samuels,
the director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism
and it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to the next in our Benjamin
and Barbara Zucker Lecture Series.
It's an especially great pleasure
to welcome today's speaker
Adam Stern back to Yale.
Some of you remember that Adam
was a post-doctoral fellow
in our program a few years ago
when he was finishing up the book
that he's gonna be
talking about today called
"Survival: A
Theological-Political Genealogy"
which has now been released
by University of Pennsylvania press,
and I just received my copy yesterday.
Adam received his BA from Columbia,
his MA from University of Chicago
and his PhD from Harvard
in the study of religion.
He's now an assistant professor of German
at the University of Wisconsin, Madison,
where he teaches courses
on continental philosophy,
Jewish thought, race and
religion, secularism,
political theology, translation
theory and media studies.
He's gonna be in conversation
today with my colleague
in the German department, Paul North.
Paul is well known to most of you.
Among other things, he's the author
of "The Yield: Kafka's
Atheological Reformation"
published by Stanford in 2015,
and a new book that I have
to say sounds incredibly cool
called "Bizarre-Privileged
Items in the Universe:
The Logic of Likeness",
literally just out last
week from zone books.
So here's how things are gonna work,
Adam is gonna present his
book for about 10 minutes,
then Paul will engage him in conversation,
then we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
Please submit questions
using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen, not chat.
You can submit questions at any
time during the presentation
and Paul will ask them,
and we're gonna finish promptly at six.
So I will now mute my video
and hand it over to Adam.
- Thanks very much Maurice
for the kind introduction
and for hosting this event and,
also to Paul North for
agreeing to participate
and to Inessa Laskova for
helping to organize the event.
So as Maurice said,
I'm just gonna speak for a few minutes
and then we'll proceed
with some discussion.
So my book began with a few observations.
The first was that survival
occupies a prominent place
within the modern, secular
political imagination.
When you only think of the ways
that the figure of the survivor
has come to mediate the
representation of current events
from genocide, climate
catastrophe and mass shootings
and disaster capitalism to
nuclear war, terminal illness
and perhaps in the post-Holocaust
present everyday life.
The second was that
one could also identify
a popular association
between survival and Jews.
Considered here not only the primacy,
accorded to the Holocaust
survivor in our time
but also the extent to which survival
underwrites the narration
of both Jewish history,
the survival of the
Jews and Jewish politics
the survival of the Israeli state.
The question I wanted to ask was this,
what if anything unites
these two horizons,
could an examination of secular survival
shed light on the issue
of Jewish survival?
And what could a study of Jewish survival
tell us about the dissemination
of survival more broadly?
It became clear at an
early stage in the research
that any attempt to write this history
would have to go beyond
two major themes or areas,
Darwinism and the Holocaust.
Neither biology nor biopolitics
seem to fully account
for the theological and
theological political resonances
of the discourse on Jewish survival.
My hunch moreover,
was that any
theological-political perspective
on survival or Jewish survival
would have to acknowledge
the code segmented
by the asymmetric legacy of
the Jewish-Christian debate.
So this gave rise to a hypothesis,
perhaps the link between Jewish survival
and secular survival could be
found in the invisible space
between and in the very
thing that otherwise
managed to erase itself from view,
the theological-political
history of Christianity.
So this book interrogates the possibility
that Latin Christianity has
played an overwhelming role
in shaping survival as a
word, theme and figure.
More than that,
the book is an attempt to
follow the language of survival
as it modulates,
disarticulates, and rearranges
a number of categorical distinctions
between things like the
secular, the Jewish,
the Judeo-Christian and the Christian.
My strategy throughout is to read secular
and/or Jewish writers who have contributed
or been made to contribute
to the vast proliferation
of survival talk.
What I tend to show is
that these arguments
that appear to highlight the
secular and/or Jewish signature
of survival also consent
and even demand attention
to a different set of readings.
Again and again, they return survival
to a Latinate field of translation,
to scenes of incarnation,
passion and resurrection.
In short, to a stage dominated
by the sovereign triumphalism
of Christ's body.
In this sense, the book is less a history
of survival than a genealogy of its force.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about what I mean by
genealogy in a minute.
It doesn't seek to address
the whole of survival's manifold uses,
forge a linear narrative
of its development
or contextualize it
in reference to a single historical event.
Instead, the book moves
backward from the present
in order to rewrite the
interpretive regimes
that have dominated survival circulation.
These genealogies of
survival take major texts
of 20th century philosophy, theology
and political theory as sites
or occasions for collecting
and constellating the scattered elements
of survival's
theological-political archive.
My hope in the book is that
this will establish a framework
for thinking survival
as a Christian question
and in doing so offer
a critical assessment
of Christianity's role in
the constitution of modern,
secular and Jewish politics.
In order to frame all of these issues,
I begin with a single question, which is,
who is speaking about survival?
And the question seeks to highlight
the genealogical objective of the study.
My central purpose is not
to affirm or deny survival,
it's not to accept or reject its rhetoric
or to say yes or no to
the stances it defines.
Instead following Michel
Foucault's definition of genealogy,
or at least one of them the task
is to gauge the fact that
survival is spoken about,
to discover who does the speaking,
the position and viewpoints
from which they speak,
the institutions which prompt
people to speak about survival
and which store and distribute
the things that are said.
In other words,
I use genealogy as a
scheme for provincializing
the presumed universality of these codes
and ask how speech that has
not always been self-evident
to everyone has been made to
look obvious and universal.
My goal that is, is to say
that genealogy of survival
is not a history of survival,
but instead a way of asking
where such a history might begin?
What are survival's limits?
What are its archives?
What are its languages?
And importantly, in the book
what field of translations
mediate its generalization?
So the genealogy presented
over the course of the book
is at best a prologue to a history
that has not really been written.
Though restrictive and partial,
the aspirational constraints acknowledge
the need for a preparatory
inventory of the major questions,
texts and structures of
speaking that have made survival
an identifiable element of
our current political horizon.
In doing this, my preliminary hypothesis
is that the genealogy
of survival should begin
with the specific political
and theological-political anxieties
surrounding the survival of the Jews.
In choosing this point of departure,
I'm not arguing for a direct
and transparent return
to the Jewish textual tradition,
but rather for a more complex encounter
with the vicissitudes of
history and translation
that have contributed to the adoption
of this language by both Jews and others.
The political theorist Robert Meister
motions in a helpful
direction here, I think,
by speculating that the
political prominence
of Jewish survival is as much about Jews
as it is about the Christian West
and the history of the Jewish question
that goes as far back as Paul,
why are there still Jews?
Now this insight could take
the genealogy of survival
in a number of directions.
On the one hand, a shared
concern with Jewish survival
could serve as a means of reconciling
the commonalities of (indistinct)
that runs from the Bible
to the present day.
On the other hand, survival
could also be an opportunity
to explore the historical grammar concepts
underlying secularism.
Critics of secularism like
Talal Asad for instance,
have argued that the
Judeo-Christian heritage
assumed by modern secularity
is actually a retrospective reconstruction
whose vision of unity has
particular political stakes,
in Asad's word, "the grammatical
exclusion of Muslims".
The problem is that
neither Meister nor Asad
ever really divest
themselves of the suspicion
that the secular embrace
of a Judeo-Christian past
is really just the reiteration
of an older Christian perspective
on the theological place
of the Jews and Christiandom
that it's a kind of re-description,
a super sessional re-description
of Christianity itself.
In this light, I approached your survival
neither as a Jewish nor as
a Judeo-Christian question
but instead as a counterintuitive index
for the way that survival
explains, refracts the
secularized forms of Christianity
that marked modernity in the West.
Of course, versions of
disclaim are by now familiar.
Few philosophers of religion,
for example would be surprised
to learn that Christianity provides
the inescapable backdrop
to Western philosophy.
The same statement could apply
as much to individual
thinkers explicitly involved
in projects like detheolization
as it could to more abstract
and far reaching endeavors
to unearth the theological traces at play
in something like modern
political economy.
And yet the stark obviousness
of Christianity significance
has not necessarily led
to any further clarity
on the kind of object or
subject that Christianity is.
Which is to say that even
the most sophisticated
genealogical work sometimes struggles
to contain the slippages
between Christianity
and a host of other
historically freighted terms,
not the least of which
would be the word religion.
This translation between
Christianity and religion.
In order to open this
up in a different way,
I borrow from a term
that Dr. Derrida coined
toward the end of his career
namely global Latinization,
is kind of neo-liberalism
that attempts to combine
Latin Christianity
with the century's long
process of universalization
that Derrida also calls globalization.
Which it also implies,
for me with this term
global Latinization implies,
is that the question I've been asking
who is speaking about religion
cannot ignore the fact
that the name survival as
with the name religion,
we are already speaking Latin.
So my genealogy begins
also as an investigation
into the history of translation
as it makes its way from Rome
in terms like supravietuire,
to Europe, survival, (indistinct)
to the United States in
English again survival
and has become part again of
our current political horizon.
To borrow a quote from Saba Mahmood,
one might say that survival is symptomatic
of the fundamental centrality
of Christian norms,
values and sensibilities,
However Judaic they are made out to be
to European conceptions of
what it means to be secular.
So, one final question, before I end,
how does this work in the book?
As I've said, I look at a
series of canonical writers,
Hannah Arendt, Walter Benjamin,
Franz Rosenzweig and Sigmund Freud.
And again the question is why
these canonical and familiar names?
So just a few comments on that choice.
In choosing them, I'm
compelled by two strategies.
First, because of the
work of Arendt, Rosenzweig
and Freud has been so
central to the post-war
expression of Jewish survival,
their writings are also effective sites
for provisionally
disarticulating these two terms,
Jewish and survival.
Second, because of the writings of Arendt,
Benjamin and Freud
have circulated well beyond the
discourse on Jewish survival
and become major resources
in the propagation of survival talk
across geographic and topical contexts,
they can also serve as
occasions for reorienting
along global Latin lines,
survival's theological,
political genealogy.
Just two quick examples.
In the chapter, actually
we'll stay with one example,
in the chapter on Arendt which begins,
the claim is survival.
This word survival runs like
a red thread through the book,
"The Origins of Totalitarianism"
stringing together it's
intersecting analyses
of Antisemitism imperialism
and totalitarianism.
And so through a comparative
reading of these sections
and the respective representations
of Jewish survival,
what Arendt calls Jewish survival,
African survival and European survival,
I establish Arendt's text as
a kind of digest for thinking
about survival's
theological-political archive.
I do this across each section
until the story culminates
in a striking image that Arendt borrows
from a number of figures in her own time
that finds the description
of the concentration
camps in which the figure
of the survivor is Lazarus,
saved and resurrected from
the ruin of a ghostly realm
that Arendt herself and a
kind of racialized narrative
that has been picked up by
others continually compares
to "the dark continent".
And so survival becomes a way
of thinking about how a series
of things, religion, race,
sovereignty and so forth
can be thought within the history
of a Christian
theological-political archive
and what some of those
elements might look like.
I will stop here
and we can begin the discussion.
- Thanks Adam.
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Well, there's a lot to
take up in what you say
and a lot to take up in the book.
I appreciate having read it
and I appreciate the attempt
to save Jews from survival.
It's a loaded term as you show,
it's loaded in a whole
bunch of different ways.
In fact, it seems as you read
through the book you discover
that it is connected to so many different
problematic projects, you could
say that I begin to wonder
and this is my first question to you.
It's a general question
and then I wanna get to
some specifics in the book.
What's the alternative?
Have you thought of the real
work that this term does
for people in valorizing their experience?
I see it as,
and I'm with you in your
critiques all the way through,
I can see exactly where it comes from.
But I see it as an indicator
of an unsettled relationship
to finitude that as the
accounts have not been settled
on one's own limitations and
also on the death of others
and survival is as you show
at times a triumphant response
and at times a melancholic response
and it oscillates between the two,
but it does do that work.
- Right.
So yes, this is a crucial
question, I think,
which I'm understanding in two ways.
One is that the way that survival captures
both these triumphant moments
and this melancholic moments
or you can say ghostly moments as I talk
about in some portions of the book.
And so if survival doing
this kind of important work,
if it's capturing not
just one particular figure
but a whole range of possibilities
say it in a reaction to finitude
or reaction to the death of others,
then is there an alternative
or should we hold onto
survival for some reason?
And I think that's completely possible.
It's possible to make an argument
that we should hold on to survival
as doing some kind of work.
My sense is that actually
even in places like the popular media,
there's something pushing against survival
and even the figure of the survivor
not simply because of the content
that it holds
but also perhaps because of
the assets that it creates
or the obviousness of the
terms that it brings together.
For one thing, I think it still is related
to a kind of post-Holocaust discourse that
has certain familiar
images, certain familiar
figurations that have come
to color all sorts of things
as I point out in the introduction
related to the cold war and so forth.
And the question is whether
beginning elsewhere is possible.
And this is something that I
suggest at the end of the book
with an attempt, with a kind
of displacement of translation
to think outside the history of,
Latin Christianity and
in relation to a series,
kind of figure of translation
in Hebrew and Arabic
that would provide not
necessarily a postwar American
or post-Holocaust orientation
but maybe a kind of post-colonial
decolonial orientation
to thinking about some of the
similar questions of finitude
and so forth that you bring up.
Just one other example though,
I think survival also creates
a kind of problematic bind.
There are two recent books
that I've found helpful
in thinking about this.
One is a kind of ongoing
project summarized recently
by Muhammad Mamdani
where he tries to suggest
that what's so important about
the figure of the survivor
in say post-genocidal context
is the way that it overcomes
the difference between
victim and perpetrator
and that it can actually, for that reason
be a kind of reconciliatory
term for thinking about
those who have
survived,
a genocidal context.
On the other hand, there's another book
that's come out recently by
(indistinct) short tennis
scholar in Boston who suggests
that the triumphalism of the
survivors always connected
somehow to settler colonial movements
or the triumph of the survivor
as the triumph of the
perpetrator, always in some way,
this overcoming of victimhood,
the death of others,
the denial of the pacivity of victimhood.
And so for that reason,
you're caught somehow
in a double bind, what kind
of work is survival doing?
Is it a kind of productive agency
or is it a denial of
another mode of subjectivity
that wouldn't have that
triumphalism kind of baked into it?
- Yeah, that's a great point.
Maybe we could talk
then about your reading
of Agamben and,
the idea of the Muselmann.
So the book takes you
through a whole series
of versions of survival.
I can just read some of them,
survival of, as you said, the "savage"
which is a shocking
revelation about Arendt's
thought of what she
calls the dark continent.
The fortleben or the living
forth of texts in Benjamin,
the imitation of Christ in Rosenzweig,
the Eucharistic presence
of the absent body of God,
which also shows up as a
gesture of media and so on,
there's a number of them.
But then you've got towards
the end to the question of,
a social relationship where the survivor
is always a survivor with relationship
to someone who's life doesn't
count, even if they survive.
Would you talk a little bit about that?
- Sure, thank Paul.
Can you just tell me what
point you're referring to
at the end?
- I'm trying to find it
here in my various notes.
I think I'm talking about...
- I can answer in relationship
to Agamben if that helps.
- Why don't you do that and
then I'll look for my...
- I mean, so right.
So, famously Agamben makes this argument
about survival in
remnants of Auschwitz as a
kind of actually intervention
into this famous difference
that Foucault suggests
between making die and making live,
Agamben suggests to make survive
as a kind of mechanism of differentiation
between say survivors on the one hand
and what he calls the Muselmann
or the Muslim in Auschwitz
which has been of course
written about extensively.
And what I try to do
is not so much disagree
with Agamben but suggest that
his own genealogical work
in remnants of Auschwitz
ends up preening kind of distinction
between the theological, say,
the remnant of Israel
and the biopolitical which
he associates with survival.
But that his actual genealogy of survival
although alluding at moments
to a theological heritage
never really doubles down on that
and keeps these two things separate,
the biopolitical and the theological.
And what I try to suggest then is that,
oddly enough, maybe not,
oddly, I don't know, one can
actually think about the way
that Franz Rosenzweig's
book written well before
the context that Agamben is writing about
already seems to be
working across similar lines in the sense
that the survivor has this
triumphalist aspect to it
that the Muslim is coded according
to a particular history of despotism
that marks the Muslim with death
and that the entire discourse
of survival in Rosenzweig's
book somehow circles
around his understanding
of the body of Christ.
And so in that sense,
Rosenzweig's book becomes
a kind of supplement,
I don't know, retrospective
supplement to Agamben's work
to suggest that this isn't maybe about
the Holocaust itself but
there's an older lineage
for thinking about the way
that the language of survival
mediates our reception of things like
those whose lives matter,
those whose lives don't matter
as you put it earlier.
- I see.
So just to go a little
further with the distinction
between the theo-political use of the term
and reception from a
Christian theological past
which you trace back to
Pseudo-Dionysius and Neoplatonism
and the biopolitical,
I can see very much the
stakes with the biopolitical
which is a term invented by
Foucault in late lectures
to talk about the way governments
manage biological life
of the governed.
And so the idea of survival
in a biopolitical realm
could issue in violence
against the physical life
of certain members of the community,
the kind of logic of sacrifice there.
What are the stakes of the theo-political?
Is it just that people
are Crypto-Christians
that kind Arendt or Benjamin, maybe less
and they're waiting for an
afterlife, a perfect life?
In some sense you suggest
this in Rosenzweig's,
the end of Rosenzweig's book
where one goes into life
that has to be sure and have
all its other characteristics.
It's hard to know what that is.
What are the stakes of the
theo-political reading?
What are we losing there?
- Well, let me answer
this question in two ways.
So, the first thing to say
is that I don't know that
Arendt, Benjamin,
these figures are
exactly Crypto-Christian.
At least my attempt is not to sort of make
a challenge toward any
kind of identity claim.
What I'm actually trying to suggest
is that the identity claims
sometimes predetermines
or overdetermines the way
that we read these texts.
And that in fact, one
can read books by Arendt,
by Benjamin and so forth
as helping to assemble
this theological-political archive,
especially in or particularly
in regard to survival.
The stakes, I think,
if I'm understanding
your question correctly,
and as I was suggesting as
well in the opening remarks
is that survival was already
one could say theological,
if you read the link
between Jews and survival
as marking survival in some
way with religion or theology.
And in fact, there's a whole tradition
both in modern scholarship
and in older scholarship
of trying to read Jewish theology,
the history of Jewish textual tradition
through the language of survival.
And so the stakes for me are
to disarticulate these things
and suggest that the language
of survival actually emerges
not only from a Christian
theological tradition
but actually captures Jews
as a theological category
through the language of survival,
through the Augustinian
tradition and so forth.
And it's this, call it a
theological political reorientation
but also a geopolitical reorientation
to the extent that terms
like Judeo-Christian
I think gloss over
the stakes of thinking about
what am I mean to set
Jewishness or the history
of Jewish textual tradition,
whatever it might be off
from the kind of obviousness
of survival as a link
between them.
- No, I think it's a great discovery
and it's really useful for understanding
how one is read through the other.
I guess I would say and I
wonder if you agree here
that it's a particular interpretation
of a relationship to loss,
a recuperative relationship
and I can see how the
structures that you bring in
to understand survival, the Eucharist,
the passion of Christ, God as
the ultimate ever lived and
survivor who has eternal life.
And then you raise the wonderful question,
well, what is life?
It really depends what you mean by life
when you're saying someone survives.
I think of,
Summer Morgan Stern
who was a friend of Benjamin's
who came to New York
after the war and he had survived
but he really didn't feel
like that word was the right word.
It felt like the most thin of existences.
So, well, I wanna ask
what you think about that
as a certain interpretation of loss.
And again if you have an
alternative that you wanna propose.
- Right.
I mean, I think that's right.
In all of the examples
that I give it's structured
in some way around this question of loss.
And things like the Eucharist,
God's survival, so forth
are reactions to this
possibility to finitude and loss.
So,
the question I think for
me is not whether survival
is so much a good description
of this question of loss.
As you say, it does a lot of work.
But for me I think the question is how
central
this question of survival
becomes in relationship to loss
for understanding subjectivity in general.
And to me, that's not a clear leap
and certainly the Freudian tradition,
even up through contemporary theory,
Judith Butler and so forth,
this link say between melancholia,
triumphant melancholia
and the constitution of the subject,
I think is something that
should just at least be,
thought about in this genealogical way.
And so while I do propose
a kind of alternative at some point,
my preliminary goal with
the book is to raise
these questions as perhaps
being more contingent than
they would sometimes suggest.
And so the next step then
would be to think about
what an alternative might look like.
Though I will leave that to
scholars more ambitious than I.
- Yeah.
Maybe I'll just ask you one more question
and that's about maybe the most peculiar
and complicated figure
of survival in your book.
And that is I think,
Benjamin's idea of the
fortleben of a text,
the living forth of a text
into it's (indistinct),
it's post ripeness or the
ripeness of its post age.
This is certainly not a triumphalist view
and it is
not really about human
beings in any of the senses
as quasi theological beings,
as imitations of Christ.
How do you see that fitting in?
- Right.
So I think you're right.
I think the chapter on Benjamin
stands in an interesting
relationship to the chapter
that proceeds it, Arendt,
which is about political
questions and so forth.
And some of the theological work that I do
in the rest of the book afterward,
specifically in relationship
to things concerning
Christ's body and the Eucharist so forth.
For me, Benjamin did do a couple things.
One is that to the extent
that there is a contemporary
philosophical discourse
about survival, it
emerges in a strange way
in relationship to Benjamin's
text on translation.
This apparent distinction,
it's not even clear Benjamin
makes a distinction,
but Derrida suggested at some point
that there was a distinction
between fortleben and uberleben
and that one could map
these along different lines,
living on versus living after.
So for one thing, that
linguistic difference
and its afterlife in
contemporary philosophy
was helpful for orienting the
problem as one of translation.
That one of the issues with
survival is that I wanted to use
translation to make it less
transparent as a category,
and to think about the
way that across languages
translation creates problems
for thinking about exactly
what survival was doing.
But in doing that, what I try to show
is that as much as Benjamin writes
about the fortleben of the text,
uberleben somehow
has a less clear set of uses.
And yet what I try to suggest
is that the term uberleben
itself, or that Benjamin's text
is an opportunity for
thinking about the history
of the translation of that word
and the way that Benjamin uses it.
And that there are ways of
reading Benjamin's texts
especially toward the end with the notion
of a kind of performative language that
is translatable less as survival
or translatable as survival,
but in a particular sense
of kind of hyper life
or super life.
And what I tried to show as you mentioned
is that my hypothesis is this (indistinct)
back to
the texts of Pseudo-Dionysius,
where the idea of super life
is a description of God's
sovereignties or apathetically,
registered but that this
construction of uberleben
as hyper life one can actually follow
a history of translation
through translations of Pseudo-Dionysius's
texts into German.
So Benjamin does
some work for me linguistically
and archivally, I would say
in preparation for the rest.
- Right, I found it a
really interesting chapter.
And you come back to
Benjamin later to talk
about the aura as a form of survival.
I guess I would say that
one valence of survival
is this again, in a
kind of particular spot
in a Christian tradition that
there's some precious stuff
call it spirit that has carried over.
But Benjamin when he comes to it,
really thinks nothing is carried over.
That's the interesting part of it,
that the translation touches
the original at a certain part,
but there isn't a preservation there.
So, it could offer
another model where instead of surviving
you're in fact departing
from a certain spot.
- Right, no, I think this is right and,
I mean, obviously people like
Sam Weber and so forth
have kind of opened up this term fortleben
in interesting ways and this departing
from a text into the text
of another and so forth.
And I think these readings
of Benjamin are all correct.
What's interesting actually
is in that chapter,
in the particular valence
that uberleben takes on
is it's actually not clear
that it's about preservation at all.
And then in some sense, it's
a tempt to actually understand
what do we mean to have a
language without content
that preserves nothing
but it's actually creative
as creative in some
powerful way.
And this is what I think
it does for I'm thinking
about this term, uberleben
and it's difference
if it is one from the way
that fortleben tracks this,
becoming other texts across
the rest of the essay.
- Well, terrific.
Thank you for talking with me.
I'm gonna open up the floor to questions.
- Thank you Paul, I appreciate it.
- It's a total pleasure.
I'm going to turn to the
Q&A now and I'm gonna,
well, since I didn't ask whether
people wanted to be named
I guess I won't name the people
who are asking but I
will ask your questions.
Here's a question about
Christianity as a question
and which is the Christianity
you're talking about?
He wants to know, or she wants to know
what is the state of the
Christian question in your work?
- Yes, it remains a question
or at least I think if
my understanding of the state
of the Christian question
is correct is that it is a question
that maybe is
still burgeoning strangely enough,
that it still needs to be
asked in a particular way.
And my hope then is that
this question of survival
is a way of opening up what
that question might be,
theological, political,
economic representational.
Paul and I didn't have a
chance to talk about media
but one of the frames for
thinking about the survivor
as a figure is thinking about survival
actually in relationship to
things like absence and presence
as they appear in both contemporary media
and then historically in debates
about representation in Christianity.
So, yes, so survival is a way I would say
opposing this question and
keeping it open as a question.
- Okay, I'm gonna go
onto another question.
This one says, in the opening of your book
you identify the Jewish survival,
a genealogy of survival
(indistinct) can look differently
and less Christian if
originated in the Jew
as a "stranger".
In modernity the lineage arise
from Zimmel via Boober
Benjamin and Arendt et cetera.
The stranger may point
towards a different ethics
in theo-politics of survival
and the Christianized reading by Agamben.
Curious to hear your thoughts.
- So the question is, is
whether the stranger is
potentially more productive
figure than survival?
- It seems that there
is a survival attached
to this stranger
and it might have a different
ethics associated with it.
- It might, I don't know.
I haven't thought too much
about the stranger, but,
it's an interesting pairing with survival.
I'll have to think a
little bit more about that.
I don't have anything
concrete to say at the moment.
- In your portrayals the survivor,
except maybe for Benjamin
is always our survivor.
The survivor of our group,
the survivor that belongs somewhere.
And that carries the belonging with them
even into an alien
territory exiles for one.
- Right, I mean,
this reminds me, this
is helpful, actually.
One question that,
the question of political theology
of survival brings up in relationship
to kind of famous things in
the field of (indistinct)
and so forth is the
degree to which survival
is actually is always a
function of a community,
the self and the other
multiplicity and individuality.
And so thinking about
what the stranger might be
in relationship to the way that survival
always forms a community of
saying inclusion and exclusion
could be an interesting way
of thinking about opening that up
but I'd have to give it a
little bit more thought.
- Yeah, you write in chapter
four on the sovereign
about figures of sovereignty
even in the age of pure sovereignty,
absolute sovereignty as being
kind of survivors of God.
And in a sense, the sovereign
has to survive into modernity,
sovereignty does in other forms.
The one Christ who says this is my body,
the sovereign who says
(speaking in foreign language)
has to take different forms in modernity
and already that you show
is active in "Hamlet"
where you do a marvelous
reading of "Hamlet".
I wonder if you think those forums are,
proliferating if you see them in places
as you look around now.
The ones that call back
to a theological model
that are the gods that you
believe in, in disguise.
- Well, I'm gonna keep this on
a bit of a theoretical level,
but I have been wondering recently.
And I'm actually not sure
I'm committed to this claim,
so I'll be curious to
hear what you think, Paul,
but one way of talking
about the one popular way
coming out of Foucault for
talking about the difference
between epox of say power
would be sovereignty as
a kind of singular forum.
And then something like,
you have to make die
and live versus to make live and let die.
But if I'm in the classical
absolute sovereign sense,
the sovereign is already a
kind of Eucharistic body,
it's already making live.
The community is already
sustained in some way
by the king's body.
So it is possible that
the very periodization that Foucault
uses is actually bound up some way with
this strange history of
the king's three bodies
or four bodies or however
many bodies it may have.
- Yeah, I guess in Europe
the French revolution
would be a good turning point there.
If the sovereign can carry
the survival problem
of God for the people,
the people are really free
but once the people have to carry it
and have to continually
support the sovereign
through their will then you
have to make the people survive.
It's a thought, I'm going
back to the questions.
Yes, the question is,
could you talk a little bit
or does your book talk
about the etymologies
and different linguistic
histories of the Latinate versions
of survival and the
dramatic terms that Arendt,
Benjamin, Rosenzweig use,
uberleben, fortleben.
What are the important differences
and could you talk about that?
- Right, so it does.
So the differences between
say,
German, French and English
appear throughout to the extent
that I'm reading texts that
move through these languages.
The Latin distinctions
are interesting as well.
I actually, I developed this
a little bit less in the book
than elsewhere, but
etymologically people like
Benjamin and so forth,
the term survival
has often been linked to
superstition or superstare.
And so there's actually a kind of dual
and sort of unclear etymology
of where the English term
or the French term survival comes from.
And,
it hasn't really been looked at
I think from historical
linguistic standpoint
but much like religion,
there's a kind of a doubling
of survival's genealogy
that remains unclear as to
the sort of (indistinct).
I bring this out somewhat in the book but
focus more on one than the other.
- Here's another question towards Benjamin
about super life, hyper
life and translation.
Is the super life of a
text, not it's survival
but it's fracture.
Is fracture a different mode of survival
that departs from the Christian
theological in position?
- That sounds possible.
Yes, I mean, I would
need to think about that
a little bit more in
relationship to Benjamin's text.
I mean,
the claim about the term uberleben
in Benjamin's text of the translator essay
is that actually he's
borrowing the way that he uses
the term in his essay on romanticism
as a kind of higher life but
that this isn't necessarily
the higher life of the text.
It's the
moment at the very end of the essay
when Benjamin tries to articulate the
holy text or holy,
the Bible as a text that
doesn't need to be translated
because it's already
freely translated
in the sense that it
actually produces language
as opposed to its derivative in some way.
And so uberleben
stands there.
And so this question of fracture
across the rest of the essay
it would be interesting to read
those two moments more
intention than I do in the text
and think about whether
that question of fracture
could depart in some way from
the
link between sovereignty and uberleben,
their wholeness.
- Okay, here's a question.
Thank you.
This is a question about language.
Another one, there's a
lot of interest in this.
If you premise the book upon the question
who is speaking about survival,
this here is wondering
about the preposition about,
can you separate language and speaking
as a medium of articulation
from survival as its object?
Wouldn't the speaking and the
language be a form of survival
following Benjamin, Derrida, Hammacher.
Can you talk about survival before talking
about the survival structure of talking?
- Right.
I think that sounds right to me.
Though if I'm understanding
the question correctly,
there seems to be kind
of say, Freud opposition
between what does it mean
to think about survival as a
particular word, term,
part of a particular language,
a particular translation history,
and what do I mean to generalize survival
as a kind of universalizing structure
for what it means to
speak in the first place?
And obviously in the book I
take the kind of first take,
I think that Derrida does
sort of 30 year project
of generalizing survival
has its own strategies behind it.
That survival can't be understood
necessarily the kind of
exceptional position,
but needs to be understood
as a kind of substructure
for thinking about
language, life, in general,
which is very interesting, I think
and in some ways the inspiration
for the way that this book works.
But I try to go in a different
direction by thinking
about how even that
generalization operates
perhaps within a particular
closure or particular history
of say metaphysics, Christian
theology, Christianity.
And so in that sense, it
would try to provisionalize
this claim about the
generalization of survival
as a structure of speaking.
Again, if I'm understanding this question.
- Yeah, I agree.
It would seem to me that it's begging
the question to impose survival
and language, but it's true.
The questioner is right,
that there is a kind of
circular issue there, and maybe,
it really depends on whether
we can speak differently
out of our past.
That is to use language
differently before we can start
to talk about survival differently.
I wanna ask you now,
I think we've come to the
end of our questions for now
but people are welcome to ask a few more.
We have a few minutes left.
I wanna ask you about psychology
because there's a lot of, first of all,
psychological attachment
to the idea of survival
but psychology is imagined in Freud
as you deal with him as a kind
of survival from childhood.
Can you talk about trauma
as one model of this?
Maybe you could talk a little bit about
the difference between
the psychiatric invention
of the concept of the
survivor by Robert Jay Lifton
which you address in your
prologue, your introduction
and Freud's trying to come to
terms with rests and retinols
and remainders, that seemed
to structure the psyche.
- Right, so I'm gonna try
to answer this question
a little bit obliquely, I think,
which is that one of the
arguments of the book
is that already in Freud's lifetime
but really in the post-war
period, people like Lifton
but then also important trauma theorists
like Cathy Caruth and so
forth use survival to describe
a whole series of things that
emerge out of psychoanalysis.
And,
the question I wanna
ask is whether survival
actually, as a term,
is a Freudian concept.
Which is to say in
Freud's texts is survival,
a concept like say the reality principle
or the death drive something
that Freud reflects on
as a particular category in
need of further examination.
And the turn then to this,
I read a short dream
that Freud looks at in the
interpretation of dreams,
is a place where he actually
is invested in the language of
uberleben or actually
works with a particular
word as opposed to it being
imposed on the Freudian corpus.
And what emerges from that
is this kind of strange,
transferential dialectic
between a kind of search
for a sovereign triumphalism,
what it means to stand
at a grave over the lost of a loved one.
And the sense that actually,
there are no sovereign
singular individuals.
We are all kind of ghostly replications of
everyone else and that this
is Freud's great anxiety.
And so the question for
me then is with Freud
is to try to think linguistically
or in terms of translation
about how important survival
has become to thinking
about psychoanalysis
in the post-war period.
And again, in figures like Caruth,
how it's often linked to Jewish survival.
That much of the potent force
of that comes out of a reading
of Moses and monotheism.
And so I try to move this back and suggest
that Freud's actually
working with a series,
a kind of Christian archive
in that particular moment in the dream.
- Yeah, the dream is really spectacular.
Maybe I'll just say a little about it.
We can talk about the dream
to close out the session.
Freud has a dream in which
he is in the laboratory
of his former teacher.
He hears a knock on the door
and the dead professor
Fleischer isn't there.
Incidentally, it's a fleshy visitor
whose name is Flesh,
basically middle flesh.
And Freud goes through
meeting a whole set of people
who have caused him trouble,
including priests who,
it says, kind of ego,
ideal and (indistinct)
and he's gripped by strange effects.
He sees a sign that says non Vixen
and,
he ends up thinking
that flesh had been only an
apparition to (indistinct).
It's a very complicated
dream which you carry
through the rest of the chapter.
It seems to me that whatever
there is about survival here
is really about rivalry.
In a sense you were saying that.
And I wonder if there's a real
cynical reading of survivor
here which is something like,
it is an imagined
escape from struggle or an imagined
triumph I guess in the
way we've been talking
about it but now in a social sense
where you could come out on
top without actually having to,
you know you just kill
everybody in the death wish.
- Right, right.
No, I think it's this kind of dream,
maybe it's a terrifying dream
but dream of absolute
sovereignty somehow for Freud
in this
rivalrous mode, as you've been saying.
And I think, you know, in terms
of the reception of Freud,
this is more or less confetti's
strange post-war
assessment of the survivor.
Not that the survivor is a victim
that needs to be thought of,
not in the sense of a victim
but actually "mankind's worst evil"
as he puts it in that book as
which he's taking from Freud,
the survivor as this
triumphant, sovereign figure
dreaming of killing all of those around.
And this has a kind of reception
as well into people like
Agamben and Cavalero and so forth.
So this,
peculiar language of sovereign survival
is on, in Freud, has its
own kind of resonance
into the present, I think.
And his dream, I think is one place
where you really see that happen.
- There's as usual in Freud,
there's a beautiful attack of conscience
in that the repressed
survives
but it always comes
back as something else.
So there's a disturbing
element to survival
that doesn't allow you to
triumph over anything ever.
- Right, right.
- I don't know if you would
call this survival exactly,
if something survives as
something that it never was.
And at a certain point,
I think it's Freud who talks about this
either as a childhood memory
or the stuff of psychoanalysis
or as a fantasy.
So I wonder if you would
just help us end by talking
about the kind of active and
phantasmagoric attachments
to the idea of survival.
It seems to me that
it has a lot
and it does a lot of work
psychologically even if not
in the way that Lifton imagined.
I don't know if you consider that at all
or think about testimonies
but I wonder if you could talk about that.
- Can you say a little more Paul,
sounds like you have a thought about this.
- Well, I mean, in a way,
I'm thinking that
you do this great job of genealogizing
and showing, here's a good example
and showing how these German-Jewish,
marginally Jewish,
marginally German figures
who have vexed relationships
to both take up this term
and how this offers a really good backdrop
for maybe changing our
attachment to survivor for the,
show, a discourse.
But it does seem also that there are,
let's say positive
dialectical moments to it
and it allows you to process something
or put something in a particular
place that as you say,
it holds on to complexity
as Freud as gripped by strange affects.
In a sense, because nobody
knows what it means really,
it's an ambiguous, highly ambiguous term
and it might be doing the work
of maintaining the ambiguity,
like the repressed does.
The term keeps coming back.
I wonder if you have a sense
of what its positive work is
for let's say
post show
understanding.
- Right, I mean, I think,
even historically to the extent
that some significant work
has been done on thinking about this
in the post-Holocaust period,
it's related to agency.
This idea perhaps in certain contexts,
in the post-war period,
you have a kind of lack of resistance,
"chiefs to the slaughter"
kind of accusations
or perhaps collaboration
but negatively tinged.
And survival provided a kind
of urgency for thinking about
what it might mean to find strength
in moments of suffering and so forth.
So, yeah, I mean, survival has this...
And as you said, because
it's so ambiguous,
it holds together so much
that it has this flexibility
to be used in all sorts
of different contexts,
different ways not just
extreme historical situations
but even in everyday life.
I just like (indistinct),
while it disperse on survivors,
survival is tied to a particular context.
It kind of colonizes
the whole field, right?
If it's so ambiguous and it
takes up so much perpetrator
and victim, ghostly,
multiplicity, and singularity,
it ends up being an organizing
frame for thinking about,
as I said earlier, subjectivity
in general in some way.
And the question is whether
it really has exhausted
in some way, all of the
dialectical possibilities
or if there's something
effectively familiar
about the term survival and
the figure of the survivor
and that doing this
genealogical work could provide
a kind of
set of boundaries for thinking about
what am I need to speak in different terms
even if it's in say
non-Latinate languages.
Other,
discourses that have their own politics,
their own say, materialism about them
that don't produce the same
kind of images as survival does
in their familiarity, at least.
So,
that's my sense of the issue.
- It seems like a great place to close.
- Yeah, I wanna say thank
you so much to both of you.
That was just a really
fascinating discussion.
And, to Adam,
I've just only started the book, but,
it's such an interesting
book and you describe,
you explain these concepts
in such a lucid way.
It's really, really a triumph.
And I think I really recommend to everyone
interested in these questions,
I think it's really gonna
be just an important book.
So congratulations on that.
And I just wanna end by giving
a little plug for our next
Antisemitism event which is Alex Ross.
The music critic of The New
Yorker is gonna be talking to us
about Wagner and Antisemitism co-sponsored
by the German department again.
So thank you to Paul for that.
And that is gonna be on
a Wednesday, April 28th.
So you should all get the
call to register for that.
And I hope to see you then.
Thank you again to Adam, to Paul,
to all of you and have a good evening.